-Before I ask you about
"American Idol,"
I want to congratulate you.
Nominated for
Entertainer of the Year again.
-Yes, yes. Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And you come from
a very supportive community
in country music.
Do you find -- are you
a supportive judge on "Idol"?
Is that where
you come at it from?
-Well, it's interesting.
You know, when you --
everybody wants to know, well,
who's the mean one?
Who is the one that --
that just tears them apart,
but you know, we all --
being artists, I think,
you know, we've all been there
and heard rejection and "no"
and the motivating --
the motivating sounds of "no"
as an artist.
And so, when we're dealing with
these kids, we --
you know, we're very truthful.
And I've even walked off set
and some of the people backstage
that watch the monitors,
you know, all of the people
back there.
You've got them. But anyway.
[ Light laughter ]
But they were like,
"You are really --
You were kind of stern
with them."
And I was like --
and I didn't even realize it
because I was caught up in
trying to really give them good,
you know, good advice.
You know, to carry them -- to
carry them, you know, far down
the road in music,
and it is interesting.
You know, a lot of these kids --
You know, I've lied awake
at night wondering,
"Gosh, did we make the right
decision on so-and-so?"
I mean, it's really,
really important.
And, you know, a lot of these
kids, we may --
we're not gonna bat 1.000.
We're not gonna --
We get caught up in the emotion
of it all, too,
and we have to make decisions
pretty fast.
I mean, we've got to cut them
to 100 to 50 to -- you know?
But, you know, these kids -- I'm
trying to land the plane here --
but these kids, you know,
they may go on --
[ Laughter ]
These kids will go on,
and even if we cut them,
they'll still work hard
and get record deals.
-Had you been a contestant
back in the day,
when you were their age,
how do you think would you have
come through?
-I would have been the "aw,
shucks" gullible country boy
that could -- that could sing
a little bit,
but I would have had to lean on
my charming personality.
[ Laughter ]
-My wit.
-Yeah.
You probably would have brought
a dead alligator
to prove you can do that.
-Yes, I would have proved
that ability.
But the main thing with me is
I wouldn't have known
who I was as an artist.
I think -- We've got one --
we've got one girl that's --
that's going through
the high rounds and, you know,
she's 18 years old and she knows
exactly who she is...
-Yeah, that's crazy.
-...as an artist.
I mean, if you sent her a song,
the most obscure song,
she would turn it into hers.
And she's not the best singer
in the world.
She's not the best, you know,
musician in the world,
but she is such an artist,
we can't get enough of her,
and I wouldn't have had that.
I was still trying to sing like
all my heroes at the time.
-Yeah, sure.
Well, that's nice when people
can figure it out early.